kaylee mcinerney trump 2020 senior
campaign advisor kaylee thank you for
being here
we are certainly all in the home stretch
of this election season just three days
to go
so what is what do you think is the most
important thing that president trump
could be doing right now obviously he's
holding a lot of rallies
in the next few days what is the most
important aspect of his message that you
think he should be getting out there
front and center right now
what he's doing is he's offering a
choice to the american people we had a
novel virus coming from china
the american people have a choice open
the country safely with president trump
or close down the country joe biden will
close down your schools
your churches your workplaces you have a
choice to bring back
the hottest economy in modern history
which president trump brought us
historic lows and unemployment
or go to joe biden who brought us the
slowest economic recovery since world
war ii he will raise your taxes on day
one he said so
and finally you have a choice on health
care costs are coming down premium cost
drug prices are going down you can
choose that or you can choose an into
medicare as we know it with medicare for
all which is socialized medicine
and sky-high premiums which is what we
saw under obamacare that is the choice
the american people have and they will
choose president trump on november third
kaylee where the president goes where
candidates go in the last stages tell us
a lot about what
where we are on the map and the fact
frankly that the former vice president
joe biden was in minnesota shows that
that state they normally take for
granted
is also in play we've got the president
going today
four stops in pennsylvania i believe
bucks county redding
butler will be ending outside of
pittsburgh
then he's in michigan he's in iowa he's
in north carolina
and be down in florida and georgia as
well what does his travels tell
you tell what should it tell the voters
and people watching this race
anxiously where he's going what does it
tell us about the campaign he's running
yeah it's a great question pete joe
biden biden's often confused
but right now his campaign is more
confused than ever before when you go in
one breath
to georgia and texas and then in the
next breath you go to minnesota a state
no republican has won since 1972
a state president trump almost won by
1.5 percentage points
when you're stopping by minnesota that
should worry you
that should tell the american people all
they need to know we are leading i just
checked out the numbers
uh before i came on the early vote we
are eight points
ahead and ballots returned in wisconsin
two points ahead
and ballots returned in michigan they
are on the run
to find a state they thought they had
this he hid in his basement from the
american people he won't fight for your
vote so he won't fight for you
as president so right now they're trying
to find a path to victory we are very
confident
that we are going to win in two short
days kaylee i know the election is the
front of everyone's mind right now but
we have this massive story that broke
just not long ago it said an american
hostage was rescued in west
africa in a daring raid involving seal
team six
here is a statement from the pentagon
u.s forces conducted a hostage rescue
operation during the early hours of the
31st of october
in northern nigeria to recover an
american citizen held hostage by a group
of armed men
this american citizen is safe and is now
in care
of the u.s department of state no u.s
military personnel were injured during
the operation we appreciate the support
of our international partners in
conducting this operation the united
states will continue to protect our
people and our interests anywhere
in the world kaylee what can you tell us
about what went down
in this operation it was a successful
operation
to rescue an american hostage we are so
glad to see it
under this president we've rescued 55
hostages in 24 countries and look in the
waning days of a presidency before
a massive re-election you typically
don't get a lot done
but this president is the exception he
rescued an american hostage
he secured a middle east peace deal he
put a justice on the supreme court he
visited our heroes at fort bragg that
was such a special moment
when i saw the president interact with
the army special operations
i was beautiful he spent an hour just
casually talking to them
uh joking they had a great time he
presented them an award that's the story
of this presidency
we don't stop we go to 14 states we
rescue hostages
we secure middle east peace we do it in
record time and we do it three days
before an election
kaylee it's easier for us to read the
news and say seal team six conducts
successful raid in west
africa what goes into something like
that the risk
the potential political fallout if it
went the wrong direction it takes
a lot of courage to make the political
call just as it takes the courage
to be on the ground as a navy seal but
this is not the first time we've seen
something like this from the president
whether it's al-baghdadi
or qasim sulaimani in baghdad the
killing of the iranian leader with so
much american blood on his hands
when and why does the president make
these calls
which are tough ones to make they're
very tough ones to make because you're
right it has to be conducted just
perfectly
but the president always puts the
american interest first um
it takes a lot of planning um a lot of
keeping things quiet until that moment
when you get the go-ahead and
you know i was talking to some of our
soldiers and they said to me we we pray
to get the green light because i said
you know it's got to be scary when you
go into these raids and they say we wait
for the green light and we're so proud
we have a president
that trusts us and gives us the green
light to take out al-baghdadi
to take out solemnani to take out these
horrid murderers who have killed far too
many of our american
men and women uh in battle but this
president makes the courageous and bold
decision and his record
stands and shows that well kaylee thanks
for joining us going to be a fun
exciting next three days for sure we
appreciate you being here thank you